[Music]
there is currently a lot going on in the
alien franchise for example a new film
is currently being shot in Budapest and
one or possibly even two series are in
the works the last installment alien
Covenant from 2017 was received with
mixed feelings therefore many are eager
to see how and whether the series can
reinvent itself and return to Old
familiar quality now it became known
that another Series has even been
completed but Disney is simply keeping
it under wraps it's a project that no
one had under their radar until now an
anime series titled Alien vs Predator in
a recent episode of the perfect organism
podcast producer Joshua Izzo spoke about
the series saying that it wasn't D true
that the series had been ready for a
long time yet Disney didn't seem to show
any interest in it as an outsider it's
difficult to judge the reason since
nothing is known about the exact content
of the series except that the plot is
set sometime after the Alien vs Predator
move
also revealed nothing about when the
series was commissioned by 20th Century
Fox which now belongs to Disney and how
long the production lasted from his
statements one can at a minimum roughly
assumed that it happened prior to the
release of alien Covenant at least he
was able to announce one interesting
piece of info and that was the
originally intended release of Alien vs
Predator in fact those responsible plan
to release the 10 episodes on DVD to
avoid both the streaming services and a
TV broadcast since this is extremely
unusual for Top Class Productions it
raises the question of the actual
quality of the 10 episodes and whether
it might be too low to be released Under
the Disney brand it is unclear if Disney
will still release the series or if it
may never reach the public at least some
alien fans might be interested
especially since the anime style would
be a change from previous works in the
franchise we'll keep you posted should
there be any further developments
[Music]
foreign